[Music]  you probably saw this was a very special  moment the show on last night's Oscars  Octavia Spencer won for Best Actress in  a supporting role in the movie the help  and she won is very emotional now here  to talk about her win is one of our  writers mr. Deon Cole Dioner tonight  thanks Donen it was good to see Octavia  Spencer win an Oscar for Best Supporting  Actress in the movie to help but when  she went to go at scepter war the crowd  gave us standing ovations and no one  else got one Wow  I mean it was like you know she wasn't  handicapped not like that she did a  great job like everyone else did and got  an Oscar for it all right I swear  sometimes Hollywood is just  overcompensate for their guilt towards  black people  I feel the hair work sometimes check it  out  yes  [Applause]  so please why people take it down a  notch right and let us just do our jobs  thank you very much Wow  [Applause]  [Music]